this is when wedding bells thaw and I
guess cuz it's a wedding you put on a
tie
yes is that really the only reason you
put on it tonight yeah pretty much what
else do I put on attack you should know
that by now
your randomness really is very much like
the show I just see like you're going
you're gay okay here we go here we go
I'm like yeah I'm just waiting for
something else but just because it's a
wedding episode absolutely nothing else
okay I promise it's it goes well with
the shirt thank you it covers it up but
um maybe that's why it goes well so okay
all right so this is one wedding bells
thaw we get isn't our Ice King episode
this is one where he's getting married
apparently to someone that apparently of
free of sound mind and body is going to
marry him and it turns out that she
isn't of sound mind and body she's
actually under some sort of curse or
control or brainwash or something like
that
oh yeah the the ring hypnotizes her or
at the very least takes control of her
body and the real her is like inside her
I said something along those lines so
Finn and Jake have to had to free her
from tying the knot quite literally
because he's got her tied up in this and
that and he ends up marrying Jake
accidentally cuz he stretches his arm
around and then they they get married
and I you know at the very end it's him
back in the door saying like you know
you welcome help me celebrate where am i
unmarried and I'm thinking like so wait
does that mean that he did get divorce
from Jake or is going through the
process of getting divorce and because
divorces are expensive so I just I mean
Jake's like at the very is like oh why
am i celebrate he really shouldn't as
divorces cost a lot of money well
nowadays we don't know about land oh oh
I guess it's true I said oh yeah oh is
the Canadian version of that you know
like American Canada cuz no I guess
they'd be a I have nowhere to go with
this jokes I'm just gonna
and in it so I'm trying to pick what to
really say about the Emmy it's another
Ice King episode it's just surfy and
being kind of pathetic again I guess
really really toying with the idea of
whether or not you want to keep
kidnapping princesses even though that's
essentially what he's done here yeah at
least he got someone closer to his age
what about the manlerette party uh-oh I
did like I liked that you wanted to
throw a bachelorette party
I love that calls that bachelorette
party yeah I guess they're dancing with
Teddy Graham or Care Bears whatever
those well I like how one yeah one had a
heart and another one had like it a
really angry skull and like which Care
Bear is that I don't know that better
story
angry death bear I guess so the Bears do
show up again yeah okay and I wouldn't
mind knowing more of angry death bears
story um that's a really good name angry
death bear okay I remember it bad just
okay okay i angry death bear and put a
little sea with a circle around it so
nobody will ever steal because that
stops anyone from stealing millions
you'll be able to buy two ties yes um so
yeah I'm driving a straight forward one
honestly it's like ice King's being a
jerk again and they stop it what about
the swans yeah what's up with that so
two swans are kissing what eats the
other one Bay's like have you like yeah
yeah she's happiest that's what marriage
is devouring your other half and
benignly being happy about it yeah my
wife has completely devoured me and this
is the result well that's it um the
episode is it's it's cute it's fun it's
um oh you know what the one other thing
I did like because
to remind me a lot of me in the very
opening Jake is playing the violin I
like to play violin if he alone is okay
playing the viola viola would be better
oh yeah but so he is so he's playing
that and Finn's just sitting there like
this and he it's like do you okay you
look bored or hypnotized and say no no
it's just how I listen to music is like
keep lying okay it's just like it just
holds that face and I know I get that
face like either when I'm listening to
something I like or especially I guess
people tell me whenever I'm drawing like
I mimic the face of whatever carrot
don't try so it's like someone is really
angry I'll be like no like a nobody like
you okay I'm just like no no I just like
that's how I look when I draw everyone
things like I'm really angry whenever
I'm drawing something I'm really in a
bad mood it's like no no it's just the
face I make I'm sorry I also love the
way that Jake plays the viola because
instead of you know holding it know that
stuff he's playing like this oh I didn't
even notice that explains a star holding
it like this yeah that's another thing
that was really small that I that I
really liked cuz it's so minor and it
really kind of pointless is the Snowman
for one you know he's talk did he have a
carrot on his head did I see that right
hand like three carrots or something he
had three eyes from what I guessed oh
yeah but notice we had the rocks for the
mouth and at one point in time he talks
and he has a tongue it appear in his
mouth like he had a rock tongue when we
said but the the mouth was naturally
caved in or he was just the rocks it was
just like the rock salsa no he had a
rock tongue it was this small little
minor detail on a mic yeah because he's
like it's official and when he said a
fish old the tongue came up I mean at
least it matches the mouth movements
like if they're going to break a lot the
Snowman logic that clearly is set in
stone at least they used it for good lip
movement what about the other Cruelty to
inanimate objects yeah no yeah no
there's no bullets well it takes like a
good couple seconds just to show them
having fun like laughing a jelly
it's like Rosie it's like so needlessly
curl um not as cruel as destroying old
ladies like in that one episode but but
that was all think yeah that's true
and this is something again that comes
to life and is just needlessly destroyed
it's very magical though Magic Man I
guess that's the end of this episode ok
can we ever do a V log where you don't
just leap off somewhere or just are you
ever gonna be on this episode the end of
the V log Magic Man I liked you better
when you were gone I'm not leaving this
time now you're stuck